Ooh.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to be remaking a video
that I made back in the early days of
this channel because well a lot of the
data in that video is wrong.
The topic is the 10 most widely spoken
languages in the world.
We can measure the number of speakers or
language has by looking either at native
speakers or by looking at the total
number of speakers including second
language speakers.
First we'll look at the number of native
speakers for each language and later on
we'll include second language speakers
and see how the numbers change based on
the number of native speakers.
The most widely spoken language in the
world is Mandarin.
It has somewhere between 900,000,950
5 million native speakers.
That makes it the most widely spoken
native language in the world.
By far,
mandarin is the most widely spoken of
the Chinese languages and it's the
official language of China and Taiwan.
The number of native speakers does not
include native speakers of other Chinese
languages,
only have Mandarin.
Number two is Spanish.
With somewhere between 405 million and
470 million native speakers depending on
which source you consult.
Number two used to be English,
but the number of native Spanish
speakers has been growing much more
quickly than the number of native
English speakers in recent years.
And that brings us to number three which
is English with around 360 million
native speakers.
And an interesting side note on my
previous version of this video,
I got a lot of comments saying there's
no way that the number is that low
because the population of the United
States alone is about 320 million.
Well keep in mind that a lot of people
in the United States,
a very large percentage of the
population are actually immigrants who
do not speak English as their first
language.
And that's also true of other countries
where English is the main language.
Number four is Hindu standing,
meaning Hindi and Urdu with around 355
million native speakers.
Hindi and Urdu are spoken in the Indian
subcontinent,
in India and Pakistan and they are very
similar in their spoken forms.
And they can be considered one language
even though they're literary forms are
quite different.
For more information on Hindustan each
check out my video on that subject right
here.
Number five as Arabic with around 293
million native speakers.
Now I should note that Arabic has many
different spoken varieties,
many different dialects and some of them
are harder to understand than others.
Some of them are kind of unintelligible.
For example,
Moroccan Arabic,
lots of people from other Arabic
countries say it's hard to understand
them,
but Arabic does have a standard
language.
Standard Arabic unites all of the
different dialects and people can use it
to communicate with speakers of the
other dialects.
So even though some of those dialects
are fairly different,
they can be considered one language and
if we include all varieties of Arabic,
there are 293 million native speakers.
Number six is Portuguese was somewhere
between 215,000,220
5 million native speakers.
A lot of people are surprised to hear
that Portuguese is on this list,
but remember Portuguese is not only the
language of Portugal,
it's also spoken in Brazil,
which has a population of 200 million.
Number seven is Bengali with around 206
native speakers,
mostly living in Bangladesh and in some
of the eastern provinces of India.
Number eight is Russian with around 155
million native speakers.
Number nine is Japanese with around 126
Number 10 is Punjabi with around 102
million native speakers.
It is spoken mainly in western India and
in Pakistan.
In fact,
it's the most widely spoken native
language in Pakistan even though it's
not the official language there.
Those were the top 10 languages based on
the number of native speakers,
but the situation is somewhat different
if we include second language speakers,
that's because some languages are much
more widely spoken as a Lingua Franca
than they are as a native language.
So let's see what the list looks like if
we include non native speakers.
Number one is English.
English has a lot fewer native speakers
than Mandarin Chinese does,
but if we include all the people around
the world who learned English as a
second language or as a foreign
language,
that brings the numbers up to around 1.4
to 1.5
billion speakers.
Some people estimate the number to be as
high as 2 billion,
but of course there is some disagreement
about what level of proficiency is
necessary in order to be included as a
speaker of English.
English is the defacto Global Lingua
Franca,
the international language,
sorry,
Esperanto lovers number two is mandarin
with somewhere between one point
1000000001.1
5 billion speakers.
If we include the 119 million people who
have learned it as a second language,
those people are mostly in China and
mostly speakers of other Chinese
languages.
Number three is Spanish with somewhere
between 500 million.
That 570 million speakers.
There are about 90 million people who
speak Spanish as a second language
including linguistic minorities and a
lot of Spanish speaking countries and
there are also a lot of people who
learned Spanish as a foreign language.
Number four is Hindu standing with
around 514 million speakers.
That means that there are about
200000002nd language speakers of him
understanding Hindi and Urdu function as
Lingua Franca is in much of northern
India and in Pakistan in Pakistan for
example or do a spoken as a second
language by around 94 million people and
it's only the native language of around
9% of the population.
Number five was Arabic with around 422
million speakers.
That means that there are around
130000002nd language speakers of Arabic.
A lot of these people are non Arabs
living in countries where Arabic is an
official language.
For example,
many speakers of the Berber language is
in North Africa.
Learn Arabic as a second language.
Varieties of Arabic are also used as
Lingua Franca us throughout different
parts of Africa.
Number six is a Russian with around 260
million speakers.
Russian jumped from number eight on the
first list to number six on this list.
That's because Russian is widely spoken
as a Lingua Franca throughout much of
the former Soviet Union.
For more information on Russian,
check out my video on that subject right
here.
Number seven is Portuguese with between
250 million and 260 million speakers.
There are about 35000002nd language
speakers of Portuguese,
mainly in African countries like Angola
and Mozambique countries where
Portuguese is the former colonial
language.
Today there are some native speakers
living in those countries,
but Portuguese is also used as a Lingua
Franca between the diverse linguistic
communities.
Number eight is a language that didn't
even appear on our original top 10 list
and that is the Malay language including
Indonesia,
which is a variety of Malai.
It is spoken by around 77 million people
as a native language and there are an
additional 173000002nd language speakers
for a total of 250 million speakers of
Malaysia and Indonesia.
One of the reasons that it has spoken so
much more widely as a second language is
because it is widely learned as a second
language in Indonesia.
There it is the official language,
but it's mainly used as a lingua franca
because there are hundreds of languages
spoken in Indonesia.
Number nine is Bengali with around 226
million speakers and number 10 is French
or another language that didn't appear
on our original top 10 list.
While French has around 80 million
native speakers,
there are around 140 million second
language speakers for a total of about
220 million.
The majority of those speakers are in
Africa where French is spoken and around
31 different countries.
Some researchers project that the
Francophone population will be as high
as 500 million in the year 2025 and 700
million in the year 2050 so which list
do you think is more meaningful?
I tend to think that the second list is
more meaningful because in my opinion,
the importance of a language depends on
how many people use it for communication
and not on how many people speak it
perfectly and with the perfect native
accent and I think that another thing
that makes a language important is how
many countries that is spoken in
andover,
how wide of a geographic area that has
spoken.
I think we have to balance these two
different factors in order to determine
how important the language is.
So even though Mandarin has the largest
number of native speakers and even
though it has the second largest number
of total speakers,
it might not be the most important or
second most important language in the
world.
The most important language in the world
is right now clearly English because it
is widely spoken by so many people
around the world.
I would say that number two is Spanish
because it's spoken by a large
population and it's spoken in dozens of
countries around the world.
And because the Spanish speaking
population is growing quickly,
I would say that French might be another
one in the top five because of it's
fairly large total number of speakers
because it's widely spoken in Europe and
in Africa.
And because of the projected growth in
the francophone population,
another might be Arabic because it's
spoken throughout many countries in the
Middle East and North Africa and by a
growing population in Europe and around
the world.
And another one is probably Chinese,
even though it's not an official
language in many places,
China is an important country with a
huge population and a large economy and
Chinese might become more important in
the future.
So the question of the day is,
what do you think,
what are the most important languages in
the world?
Leave your opinions and your reasons in
the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on twitter,
on instagram,
and our facebook.
And again,
I'd like to say thanks to all of my
patrion supporters.
For your continuous support.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.